everyone's still talking about Pizza rat
yeah I can't believe the two big stories
this week are the Pope visiting the US
and then Pizza rat right about there
this is of course sure this is the rat
that was the star of a viral video in
which it is dragging a whole slice of
pizza down the stairs
into the New York City Subway here's the
video that's been everywhere you've all
seen it let's take another look and
there it is he's dragging his slice down
the stairs into the subway yeah well
here's the crazy thing that happened
this happened just before the show like
an hour ago
just an hour ago the guy who took that
video released even more footage its
footage of that rat before it got to
those stairs let's take a look at the
new footage there's the rat and he's
headed into a pizzeria and he's he's at
the pizzeria probably he's hungry and
he's getting an apron and there he is
getting his little hot right there I
guess
[Applause]
he's totally good he's not
he's always bleeding and a little
trouble there he's got how he's rolling
it out you got it all that's hasta
the buzz around
a little olive oil that's a nice touch
and then right into the oven that heats
it goes she is pretty methodical about
making his hood what's he doing now I
guess he's got time to kill I don't know
what he's doing he's got time to kill
while it's cooking he's making sausage
cheese that's awesome and then now the
beach is done he's cutting it up now
he's ready to drag it into the subway
very nice
[Applause]
now are we saying that the rat snuck
into the pizza partes okay then why was
there a rat sized apron good night
everybody
wasn't that a great clip subscribe to my
youtube channel for an endless supply of
me
[Laughter]